es ist die Aufgabe des IWF Lösungen zu
finden von denen alle profitieren ihre
Umsetzbarkeit zu beweisen und dann die
G20 davon zu überzeugen
China ist zwar die zweitstärkste
Wirtschaftsmacht der Welt aber auch eine
der ärmsten
diese Krise ist ansteckend die Angst
geht um und wir müssen sie aufhalten
ich möchte unsere Regierung direkt sagen
dass sie mit der Bevölkerung
zusammenarbeiten muss
der IWF wurde mit abschall betrachtet
man riecht diese wirtschaftsschläger und
die setzten das diktatorisch
[Musik]
die Geschichte mit dem Schmetterling in
Afrika der in Lateinamerika Wirbelstürme
auslöst ist den meisten geläufig genau
um so etwas geht es hier
die Schattenseite der Verbundenheit ist
alle sind in Schwankungen bemerkte
ausgesetzt
wir brauchen bessere multilaterale
Führung
fehlt sie werden unsere Kinder und Enkel
den Preis dafür bezahlen
[Musik]
IWF muss mit der Zeit gehen er wurde vor
mehr als 60 Jahren gegründet
dass er sich anpassen muss überrascht
also so
[Musik]
wenigierten aus 44 Ländern der
Alliierten zur Eröffnung der
un-finanzkonferenz ein sie werden über
Pläne für die Währung Stabilität
sprechen
die Hoffnung und das Ziel dabei war ein
besserer Rahmen für die weltweite
Zusammenarbeit
für gemeinsame Problemlösungen und dass
die Länder für ihre nationalen Ziele
nicht die Ziele der Welt opfern würden
man wollte ein wirklich robustes und
stabiles System entwickeln
es galt dabei als unabdingbar die
Freiheit der Kapitalflüsse und des
Marktes einzuschränken
heute geschieht alles unmittelbar und in
enorme Maßstab
was auf dem europäischen oder dem
US-Markt geschieht kann verheerende
Folgen für Bauern in Afrika den Bergbau
oder indigene Völker in Lateinamerika
haben
diese Verbundenheit hat viele Vorteile
man beachtete nicht dass alles Gute auch
Schattenseiten haben könnte
die Krise zeigte uns wie groß diese
Schattenseite sein könnte
man verstand nicht dass eine Welle an
Fehlern in wenig erforschten Märkten die
Weltwirtschaft in die Knie zwingen
könnte
die Prognosen meines Büros zeigten es
würde sehr schlimm werden das
Weltwirtschaftsforum 2008 in Davos hat
begonnen
als ich nach Davos ging waren wir der
Ansicht des würde sehr schlimm werden
auf globaler Ebene wir würden weltweite
Konjunkturpakete brauchen es wird zu
einer ernsten Verlangsamung kommen die
eine ernste Reaktion erfordert
Strauss kann's Rede in der Wurst zeigte
der Welt eine neue Seite des IWF auch
weil jemand an der Spitze diese Dinge
sagte
die Leute sahen mich an als wäre ich ein
Alien vom Mars
es dauerte lange bis sie es einsam
drei Monate später im April 2008 waren
wir beim jährlichen frühlingstreffen in
Washington meine Prognose verärgerte die
Finanzminister sie hielten es für einen
Scherz
das sagten sie nicht so es war ja nicht
lustig sie sagten aber sie würden ihre
Wirtschaft besser kennen als ich sie
waren sich sicher für sie würde alles
gut laufen mit meiner Behauptung es
würde noch schlimmer lege ich total
daneben
beim jährlichen Treffen im Oktober 2008
trafen sich Leute aus verschiedensten
Ländern und sahen endlich ein dass sie
einen gewaltiges gemeinsames Problem
hatten
beim Monday morning der Montagmorgen
konnte man am Markt erkennen dass
Washington signalisierte die politischen
Entscheidungsträger hätten verstanden
sie würden die nötigen Maßnahmen gegen
die Erstarrung ergreifen und nach der
Bewältigung der Krise diese Strukturen
reparieren
guten Abend vom G20-Gipfel in London
einem Treffen auf der Suche nach einer
globalen Antwort der G20-Gipfel in
London war einmalig 20 Regierungschefs
der Welt trafen aufeinander und
beschlossen Konjunkturpakete für die
Weltwirtschaft in Billionenhöhe
diesen zwingen Menschen dazu ihre
Differenzen hinter sich zu lassen und
Probleme gemeinsam zu lösen
es war ein großes Glück dass die
Struktur der G20 und die große
Hilfsbereitschaft des IWF
Aufeinandertreffen
der Zentralbanken auf der monetären und
der Regierungen auf der steuerlichen
Seite verhinderte eine mögliche
Katastrophe
auf dem Treffen in London belebten die
Regierungschefs in gewisser Weise den
IWF als multilaterale Institution neu
Hoffnung
diese eine gemeinsame Antwort bieten
könnte
der aktuelle Aufstieg der G20 ist ein
Zeichen dass die Bedeutsamkeit
weltweiter wirtschaftliche Erholung und
des Wachstums dieser sich entwickelnden
Volkswirtschaften anerkannt wurde
Brasilien China Indien und andere sind
quasi das Rückgrat des ganzen weltweiten
Erholungsprozesses
G20-Gipfel verdreifachte die Ressourcen
des IWF einschließlich 50 Milliarden
Dollar für wirtschaftsschwache Länder
es war meines Wissens das erste Mal
überhaupt in der Weltgeschichte das so
viele Länder das gleiche Problem hatten
und zeitgleich beschlossen auf die
gleiche Weise dagegen vorzugehen
so gesehen stellt dieses bedeutsame
Ereignis die erste multilaterale
Maßnahme in dieser Größenordnung darf
die G20 haben ihre Probleme ebenso der
IWF Mode aber immer mehr Bewohner dieser
eng verletzten Welt verbinden mit diesen
Institutionen die Hoffnung auf
Fortschritt
wurde mit Abscheu betrachtet das absolut
letzte finanzielle Mittel wenn Start und
Regierung versagt hatten man rief diese
Wirtschaft Schläger und die diktierten
die Regeln
mit Afrika interagierte der IWF damals
üblicherweise nicht im Dialog
die meisten Länder darunter auch
Tansania sanderin folglich eine
alternativlose bittere Pille
infolge der Wirtschaftskrise musste sich
der IWF radikal ändern
ich denke der IWF hat gelernt das auch
gute wirtschaftliche Ratschläge nicht
wirken
wenn sie Politik und Gesellschaft außer
Acht lassen
[Musik]
die Konferenz in Tansania war Teil eines
Beratungsprozesses des IWF mit
verschiedenen Teilen der Welt Afrika
hatte bei dem Treffen klare Ziele
wir hatten erwartet dass bei diesem
Treffen die Stimme von Afrika gehört
werden würde
wenn man behördliches Versagen in der
gleichen Größenordnung wie in den USA in
einem afrikanischen Staat hätte würde
der IWF über uns herfallen
ich war im Laufe meiner Karriere auf
einigen derartigen Konferenzen
dieses Treffen war sehr ehrlich
wir erwarteten Veränderungen vom IWF und
die Gespräche auf dieser Konferenz
treten sich um genau diese Probleme
das Versprechen eingehalten
[Musik]
sie versprachen unter anderem einen
flexibleren Umgang mit diesen
Partnernetzwerk
das wurde mittlerweile in den meisten
Ländern offensichtlich umgesetzt
im Gesprächen bemerkte ich die
veränderte Einstellung der afrikanischen
Finanzminister gegenüber dem IWF
als Organisation die in Krisen helfen
könnte anstatt zu unterdrücken
nach der Asienkrise verspürten als der
IWF Ihnen in dieser schweren Zeit im Weg
stand wandelte sich während dieser Krise
viele Länder hatten den Eindruck der IWF
würde ihnen jetzt helfen
seien wir mal ehrlich
die ganzen Nachwehen der Asienkrise
ebenso wie die Nachwehen der
lateinamerikanischen Schuldenkrise
aufgrund derer
nicht nur schwierig als globale
Institution der alle angehören
darstellen konnte
ich denke die haben wir wohl überwunden
wir wollen das
I don't mein Wunsch mein Traum einer
koordinierten Wirtschaft wird sich wohl
kaum über Nacht erfüllen aber der
Fortschritt geht in die richtige
Richtung
guten Abend nach 18 Monaten überwindet
Großbritannien die Rezession eine
Handvoll Finanzbericht der wirkt
Hoffnungen auf eine wirtschaftliche
Erholung
als sich die Finanzkrise beruhigte
kehrten einige Staaten für ihren
nationalen Plänen zurück und handelten
nicht mehr im Einklang mit den Plänen
anderer Länder
warum hat die Weltwirtschaft wieder
Probleme
die Erholung verlangsamt sich und die
Finanzmärkte werden wieder nervös
es ist klar dass die Lösung global und
nicht national Erfolgen
von der alle profitiert zeigen dass sie
funktioniert und dann die G20 und die
Regierungen allgemein davon überzeugen
wir brauchen eine Institution die sich
tagtäglich mit diesem Problem befasst
deren Job es ist sich von früh bis spät
Gedanken darüber zu machen und
kontinuierlich an der Umsetzung zu
arbeiten auf nationaler Ebene geht es
nicht
der Zweck der Institution ist es den
Regierungen souveräner Staaten bei der
Kommunikation miteinander zu helfen
sie manchmal in ihre Schranken zu
verweisen und ihren Bürgern auf lange
Sicht etwas Gutes zu tun
die Sorge ist dass ohne echte
Veränderungen in der Politik nichts
vorangehen wird man muss auch an die
Regierungen denken nicht nur an den IWF
der IWF war Teil des Problems
jetzt geht es darum wie sie Teil einer
Lösung werden
proaktiv handeln die Bank sein die
zuhört
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wir können davon ausgehen dass
irgendwann vielleicht in der Mitte des
Jahrhunderts China 15 bis 20% der Welt
ausmachen wird ich halte das für etwas
Gutes
wie kann China das aber aufrechterhalten
China ist zwar die zweitstärkste
Wirtschaftsmacht der Welt aber auch eine
der ärmsten
[Musik]
wenn wir über die Rolle des IWF in der
Welt sprechen ist China ein sehr
erfolgreiches Beispiel
[Musik]
30 Jahren jedes Jahr ein Wachstum von
etwa 9,5%
dem zufolge verdoppelt sich die
Wirtschaftsleistung Chinas etwa alle
acht Jahre
somit ist China seit den Reformen von
1979 vor über 30 Jahren von einem der
ärmsten Länder zur zweitstärksten
Wirtschaftsmacht der Welt geworden
ich bin der chinesischen Volksbank in
den frühen 1990er Jahren beigetreten am
Anfang des Wechsels von einer
Planwirtschaft zu einer
marktorientierten Wirtschaft
das war eine gewaltige Herausforderung
der IWF verfügt über einen großen
Erfahrungsschatz
der IWF arbeitete sehr eng und positiv
mit China zusammen über viele Jahre
hinweg einige unserer Mitarbeiter sind
dort stationiert das ist seit über 20
Jahren so die Ratschläge des IWF an
China basierten auf dem was wir in
anderen Ländern beobachteten die
ähnliche Probleme hatten
china hat viel für erfolgreiche Reformen
getan
dabei hat der IWF eine sehr konstruktive
und positive Rolle
[Musik]
gespieltischen Wachstums liegt wohl im
starken Rückgang der Armut in China
[Musik]
Anfang der 1980er Jahre lebten über 50
Prozent der Menschen in China in
bitterer Armut heute sind es weniger als
8%.
hochgerechnet auf beinahe anderthalb
Milliarden Menschen in China wurden über
400 Millionen Menschen aus der Armut
befreit
das Besondere am chinesischen Modell ist
die starke Führung durch den Staat das
zeigte sich besonders bei der Reaktion
auf die Krise
man brachte ein beinahe einmaliges
steuerliches Konjunkturpaket hervor
auch die finanziellen und monetären
Maßnahmen waren erstaunlich
wir unterstützen die Reaktion wir
glauben dass Konjunkturpakete Regierung
hat geholfen
es kam zur rechten Zeit und half die
schlimmsten Folgen für die Wirtschaft
abzufedern
Chinas Exporte brachen ein und die
Regierung musste einschreiten um die
Wirtschaftsleistung zu stützen
sie taten das durch Investitionen in
Straßen Infrastruktur und das
Gesundheitswesen wodurch sie ihr
angestrebtes Wachstum erreichten
[Musik]
viele unserer Klienten profitierten von
den Konjunkturpaketen
seit Jahren kontinuierlich weiter
gewachsen
die größte Herausforderung für China ist
es die Abhängigkeit von ausländischer
Nachfrage zu verringern
aktuell ist die Nachfrage in China viel
zu niedrig
der Binnenkonsum ist selbst global
betrachtet auf einem historischen
Tiefstand
ich habe den Eindruck die chinesischen
Behörden wissen dass sie das Wachstum
neu balancieren müssen weg vom
gewaltigen Fokus auf Export und hin zu
inländischer Nachfrage insbesondere beim
privaten Verbrauch die Finanzmärkte
auszubauen wird wichtig sein ebenso wie
eine starke Währung der Wechselkurs ist
ein wichtiger Baustein für Reformen um
die Wirtschaft neu auszubalancieren
prinzipiell konzentrieren wir uns darauf
den Konsum zu fördern und den Aufbau der
Dienstleistungsbranche zu unterstützen
wenn man viel in Sozialleistungen
rentenprogramme medizinprogramme für
ländliche Regionen und dergleichen
investiert wird man Ergebnisse erzielen
der inländische Verbrauch der
Einzelhandel und die binnen Nachfrage
werden steigen
Grund für den geringen Konsum in China
ist die Sorge der Menschen um ihre
Altersvorsorge die fehlende
Krankenversicherung und die befürchteten
Ausgaben für die Bildung ihrer Kinder
[Musik]
wir sind froh wenn wir gesund sind
werden wir krank brauchen wir Geld fürs
Krankenhaus
darum sparen wir jeden Monat etwas Geld
als ich jung war hatte ich nicht genug
zum Sparen
wofür sollte ich auch sparen
[Musik]
ich erlebte in meiner Kindheit die
Planwirtschaft das Leben war damals sehr
hart es gab aber nur wenig Druck wir
waren alle in der gleichen Lage
die Trennung von Arm und Reich war
damals nicht allzu ausgeprägt
die Einkommensungleichheit in China war
früher sehr flach ist heute aber
ziemlich ausgeprägt das fällt besonders
in einem Land auf in dem es vor einigen
Jahrzehnten eben keine
Einkommensungleichheit gab
[Musik]
china ist ein Entwicklungsland und wird
noch lange ein Entwicklungsland bleiben
wir müssen die Entwicklung
wissenschaftlich betrachten und unser
Wachstum dann nachhaltig und ausgewogen
gestalten
dass es im Hinblick auf das Einkommen
nicht das obere Mittelfeld erreichen
könnte
sie machen sich Sorgen dass sie Wachstum
einbricht und sie nicht die letzten 100
Millionen Menschen aus der Armut
befreien können
die typischen Sorgen eines
Entwicklungslandes
[Musik]
die Anstrengungen der Regierung das
Rentensystem massiv auszuweiten und die
öffentliche Gesundheitsversorgung zu
verbessern sind Schritte in die richtige
Richtung die wir unterstützen
es stehen noch viele weitere schwierige
Maßnahmen an allen voran die Lage der
Wanderarbeiter
[Musik]
ich kam 2009 erscheint sein und
verdiente 900 Jahren als Mindestlohn
jetzt sind es 1.100 wir geben aber knapp
300 für Essen aus die Erhöhung ist ein
Witz
oder viele Firmen Leute einstellen viele
Leute suchen Arbeit der Konkurrenzkampf
das Gehalt ist nicht gut die
Unterbringung und das angebotene Essen
ebenso wenig ganz besonders die
Unterbringung oft stehen mehrere
mitgenommene Betten in einem winzigen
Raum die Betten in manchen Fabriken sind
voller Flöhe
China wurde immer urbaner
die Politik ging mit der Spaltung
zwischen Stadt und Land so um dass die
Integration ländlicher Bevölkerungen
vereinfacht wurde
durch diese besser von der Stadt
profitieren können
china könnte als Verbrauchermarkt zur
Triebfeder der Weltwirtschaft werden
durch die Probleme der Wanderarbeiter
und die Art wie verhindert wird dass sie
in Städten sesshaft werden sind hierbei
ein großes Hindernis
Chinas Konsum ist zu niedrig die
Fehlannahme besteht darin den Konsum als
gesondertes Problem zu betrachten das
unabhängig von großen Reformen am
Wachstumsmodell gelöst werden kann
dementsprechend muss die Gleichheit
gefördert werden
Produktivität anstatt billiger Arbeit
Innovation anstatt dem bloßen Export
möglichst viele Güter in alle Welt all
das erfordert viel besser ausgebaute und
transparentere formelle Institutionen
damit Investoren und Haushalte sich
trauen zu investieren und Innovation
Ausgaben und konsumwagen
[Musik]
die Herausforderung besteht darin dass
das Bruttoinlandsprodukt von China zwar
jedes Jahr wächst
wir aber mehr und mehr durch
Einschränkungen gebunden werden
insbesondere im Hinblick auf Ressourcen
Energie und Umweltauflagen
durch die Anpassung an andere Länder
infolge des chinesischen Wachstums wird
China einigen als Bedrohung erscheinen
es wird immer deutlicher dass Chinas
Wachstum auf andere Länder überschwappt
um politische Differenzen zu besprechen
[Musik]
eine entscheidende internationale
Plattform über die die internationale
Gemeinschaft China besser kennenlernen
konnte
während China mehr über den Rest der
Welt erfahren konnte
[Musik]
es ist eine Goldgrube
aber niemand weiß wie lange die
Ölvorräte halten werden
wir sehen das Öl als
zweite Chance für das Land
[Musik]
die Regierung gerät unter Druck
es muss ein Erfolg werden
ich möchte unsere Regierung direkt sagen
dass sie mit der Bevölkerung
zusammenarbeiten muss
[Musik]
2007 hieß es in den Nachrichten das in
Ghana herausragende Ölvorräte gefunden
worden waren wobei die Größe des Ölfelds
noch ungewiss war es war aber klar dass
Ghana sich den afrikanischen
Öllieferanten anschließen würde
wenn die Ölförderung läuft steigt das
Einkommen in Ghana wahrscheinlich um
etwa 20%. die Steuereinnahmen werden
5-6% von Bruttoinlandsprodukt ausmachen
das ist enorm denn Ghana hat gerade
große Geldnot
[Musik]
2008 hatten wir nicht nur
Schwierigkeiten aufgrund der
Weltwirtschaftskrise wir hatten auch
selbst viel viel größere Schwierigkeiten
mit der internen Verwaltung unserer
eigenen Wirtschaft
2008 wurde gewählt in
wahljahren geht in unserem Teil der Welt
immer die Haushaltsdisziplin verloren
am Jahresende war das Haushaltsdefizit
auf einem rekordhof beinahe 20%. dazu
kam auch noch ein Handelsdefizit von
fast 20 Prozent
so den Anbetracht dieser Schwierigkeiten
hätten wir keine andere Wahl als den EWF
um stabilisierungshilfe zu bitten
ist seit langem wichtig für Ghana
dabei Probleme aber wir hatten auch gute
Zeiten
manchmal kamen dabei Programme heraus
die nie wirklich beliebt waren aber
letztendlich brauchte Ghana den IWF
einfach
die Finanzhilfen beliefen sich auf etwas
über eine Milliarde US-Dollar
und der IWF konnte auf der anderen Seite
auch die technischen Hilfen erhöhen die
Ghana erhält
der IWF kam nach Ghana und fragte dort
was die Menschen und die Regierung
wollten
sie stellten weniger Bedingungen als bei
der Finanzierung Ghanas in den 1980er
Jahren die Lage war ganz anders die
Regierung von Präsident Milz übernahm
2009 ein Land mit vielen Problemen aber
die Wirtschaftslage war nicht
aussichtslos
Gewinde der IWF hat viel Erfahrung bei
der Beratung von Ländern in Afrika
südlich der Sahara und anderen Ländern
mit reichen Ölvorräten
wir glauben daher gana mit praktische
Erfahrung helfen zu können Ghana war
gerade zu erpicht darauf von anderen
Ländern zu lernen
[Musik]
eine Abhängigkeit von Rohmaterialien
oder natürlichen Rohstoffen führt nicht
zu einer Verwandlung der Wirtschaft
trotz unserer gewaltigen Goldvorkommen
konnten wir die so sehr erhoffte
wirtschaftstransformation nicht
erreichen
nichts wenn der durchschnittskanal keine
Bildung bekommt
das Öl bringt nichts wenn die Menschen
keine gute Gesundheitsversorgung im
Krankenhaus bekommen können
alles Öl der Welt bringt nichts wenn
viel zu viele junge Mütter bei der
Geburt ihrer Kinder sterben
die erste Aufgabe ist die Verwandlung
der Wirtschaft dahingehend das
Wertschöpfung stattfindet und wir mehr
Mittel bekommen um die Wirtschaft zu
betreiben und den Lebensstandard der
Bürger zu verbessern sie auszubilden
Sozialkapital zu erschaffen und für
Bildung Wasser Gesundheit und
Infrastruktur zu sorgen
es ist für die Ganache Regierung sehr
wichtig
Investitionen mit hoher
Gewinnwahrscheinlichkeit zu finden
damit auch wenn das Ende der Ölförderung
kommt diese Investitionen weiterhin
Gewinne abwerfen
[Musik]
richtig genutzt kann das Öl den Rest der
Wirtschaft ankurbeln
wir müssen unseren Ansatz völlig ändern
und verstehen dass wir zwar natürliche
Ressourcen haben unser größter Schatz
jedoch all die Menschen in unserem Land
sind
[Musik]
in Ghana wird debattiert wie mir Ghana
er in die Ölindustrie eingebunden werden
können man redet dabei von lokalen
Inhalten
ich habe das Projekt gestartet weil ich
glaube dass junge Leute die Möglichkeit
brauchen an der neuen Öl- und
Gasindustrie die hier entsteht
teilzuhaben und mitzuarbeiten
ich bin Maschinenbauingenieur brauche
aber noch Training um in der Öl- und
Gasindustrie arbeiten zu können
gut
er
Menschen Möglichkeiten gibt werden sie
wertvolle Bürger ansonsten werden sie
ein Problem für die gesamte Gesellschaft
wir haben viele Jugendliche hier in der
Region und bitten das gesamte Land und
die Regierung den Jugendlichen hier
Arbeit zu geben
wir sind ein Entwicklungsland und
relativ arm die Menschen können es nicht
erwarten die Armut und die
Unterentwicklung abzuschütteln die
Erwartungshaltung ist dann nur
verständlich
es ist in allen Regionen das gleiche wir
müssen viel mehr auf Bildung setzen
vermitteln dass sich die Situation der
Menschen hier nicht über Nacht ändern
wird
es muss ein schrittweiser Prozess sein
wir haben viel Aufwand betrieben um
einige Schwierigkeiten und
regierungsanstrengungen diesbezüglich zu
erklären
natürlich hören wir auch auf die Sorgen
der Bevölkerung
Öl ist kein nachwachsender Rohstoff
wir wissen nicht wie lange Ghana Öl
fördern kann also ist nicht nur die
Ölbranche wichtig
es wäre wohl wichtig die Gewinne aus der
Ölförderung in Unterstützung für
Kleinbauern zu investieren
[Applaus]
Landwirtschaft ist ein Hauptelement
unserer Wirtschaft sie beschäftigt die
meisten Menschen hier viele sind auf sie
angewiesen sie leistet den größten
Beitrag zum Bruttoinlandsprodukt
die Landwirtschaft in gerna war früher
vollständig subventioniert dann
teilsubventioniert und irgendwann
bekamen die Bauern gar keine
Subventionen mehr
wir brauchen Dünger wir brauchen Geld
wir müssen die Felder bereiten und dann
brauchen wir Pflanzen die wir anbauen
können
das Geld ist wichtig denn ohne Geld
können wir wieder dünner noch Pestizide
kaufen
wir bekommen keinen Kredit wir können
keine Gentechnik nutzen auch wenn wir
die Technologie fördern
wir die kanadische Landwirtschaft
weiterentwickeln wollen
[Musik]
in anderen Ländern in denen Öl ein
Faktor war ging der Agrarsektor unter
man muss seine Wirtschaft so verwalten
können dass das Öl welches nur wenig
Arbeit schafft andere Bereiche nicht
beeinträchtigt die Menschen beschäftigen
und vor der Armut bewahren
bei einem Ölboom bleibt der Bereich der
Konsumgüter wie zum Beispiel die
kakaobranche auf der Strecke
wir greifen jedoch Maßnahmen damit das
hier nicht passiert
aber wir müssen unsere traditionelle
Lebensweise bewahren
[Musik]
überall Verlangen nach Transparenz sie
wollen keine Korruption sie wollen nicht
dass die Gewinne aus dem Öl der Willkür
der Menschen in der Regierung zum Opfer
fallen
wir haben mit Ghana daran gearbeitet die
Haushaltung zu verbessern und sowohl den
Parlament als auch der Zivilgesellschaft
als Ganzes ein Verständnis ihre Finanzen
und der Verteilung ihre Ressourcen zu
vermitteln
bis 2020 zu einem Land mit mittlerem
Einkommen machen
aber die Regierung muss sehr zielstrebig
und diszipliniert darauf hinarbeiten
[Musik]
wenn es uns gelingen soll werden wir das
Öl als Impulsgeber für die ersehnte
Transformation brauchen
vielleicht werden wir dann zu einem
positiven Beispiel und einer Inspiration
für ganz Afrika
[Musik]
[Applaus]
Mittel und Osteuropa hat die Finanz- und
Wirtschaftskrise wohl schlimmer erwischt
als den Rest der Welt dann
allerdings mit Ausnahme von Polen
Polen ist als einziges EU-Land nicht in
eine Rezession gefallen
hat die Chance nicht weniger als eine
europäische Wirtschaftsmacht zu werden
die Solidar nur feiert ihren 9
Geburtstag sie hat die polnische Politik
transformiert und führt nun die
Regierung
das Versprechen von 1989 war das Ende
der sozialen Spaltung mit dem Ende des
Kalten Kriegs
nach 1989 waren wir alle der Meinung es
gebe nur einen unausweichlichen Weg eine
Richtung
wir hatten keine Zeit für Debatten denn
wir mussten zu westlichen Ländern
aufholen
hat er eine große Krise hinter sich und
musste einen Weg finden sich in die
moderne Welt einzufügen die gesamte
Wirtschaftsstruktur ändern und
wettbewerbsfähig werden eine
kapitalistische westliche Wirtschaft
aufbauen
man kommt nicht umhin zu sagen dass
viele die Änderungen des Systems freudig
begrüßten
gleichzeitig waren sie überrascht weil
sie viel zu plötzlich die volle
Verantwortung für ihr Leben übernehmen
mussten
für gebildete Menschen in großen Städten
die jung genug waren um sich auf dem
Markt zu behaupten weiß großartig aber
ein großer Teil der Gesellschaft blieb
außen vor und wurde frustriert
die Arbeitslosenzahl wird dieses Jahr
eine Million erreichen das Arbeitsamt in
Warschau ist ausgelastet wie noch nie
vor einem Jahr war fast niemand
arbeitslos gemeldet jetzt gibt es in
Polen 400.000 Arbeitssuchende
vielen viele schwer wieder Arbeit zu
finden und die die es nicht schaffen
würden an den Rand der Gesellschaft
gedrängt sie waren
die Verlierer die Chance dass es
funktionieren würde war ein Dokumenten
des IWF auf 50% beziffert worden
die Politik war jedoch fest entschlossen
und hatte den Mut es durchzuziehen wir
hatten keine andere Wahl als diese
mutigen Reformer zu unterstützen
wir werden ihre Regierung bei der
Gestaltung ihrer Programme helfen
in der design of its Programm es ist die
Aufgabe des IWF in solchen Fällen mit
unserem Wissen und unsere Erfahrung
bezüglich dieser Probleme zu helfen
es war nicht nur die kommunistische
Wirtschaft es fehlte auch die Kompetenz
eine Marktwirtschaft zu betreiben
auf technischer Seite war die Hilfe
unbedingt nötig
[Musik]
für mich war das großartig denn wenn
jemand eine gute Idee und ein wenig Geld
hatte war das eine große Chance etwas
auf die Beine zu stellen
für uns wichtig dass unsere Produkte
unsere Kunden helfen
die Menschen in Polen waren schon immer
sehr individualistisch sie mochten es
nicht herumkommandiert zu werden
wenn man sein eigener Boss ist
kommandiert eine niemand herum
ich habe diese Firma vor 20 Jahren mit
meinem Partner in einer Garage gegründet
zu zweit
wir nutzten damals nur Bargeld
Geld wechselte schnell den Besitzer
wir konnten neue Dinge und Maschinen
kaufen
es war sehr einfach
darum ging es in Polen bei fast allen
wirtschaftlichen Unternehmungen reich
und normal zu werden
der anfängliche Erfolg kam vom
polnischen Unternehmergeist der große
Schritt vorwärts kam jedoch dadurch dass
Polen für Investitionen attraktiv wurde
Remixes
der Markt entwickelte sich das
Warenangebot wurde immer reichhaltiger
sie hatten so viele Jahre langen
hausgemachte Armut gelebt dass wir es
sehr genossen
hergestellt zwar von ausländischen
Marken aber die Produkte kommen von hier
unser Wachstum war nicht allzu
beeindruckend die ersten Jahre lagen wir
minus aber nach einer Weile wuchs die
Wirtschaft immer schneller bis wir Mitte
der 1990er Jahre 7% Wachstum erreichten
eines der Länder beim Empfang zur
Erweiterung der EU war Polen das größte
der zehn neu beigetretenen Länder was
aber bedeutet die EU-Mitgliedschaft für
die Menschen dort
in Polen war der Wunsch nach Arbeit und
einem normalen wohlhabenden Land groß
sie taten alles dafür und erreicht mir
jetzt hier
alle wollten der eu-beitreten gesammelt
schon lange als unsere Schicksal
wir wollten auch dazu gehören
[Musik]
die Transformation war sehr schnell und
umfassend
heute haben die meisten sich damit
angefreundet aber damals gab es ganz
klar Verlierer
[Musik]
beim Wechsel vom Sozialismus zu einer
Marktwirtschaft wächst die Ungleichheit
natürlich immer
das Beispiel Polens zeigt jedoch dass
die Länder die sich am schnellsten
reformierten den geringsten Zuwachs der
Ungleichheit erlebten
der Kollaps der Lehman Brothers versetzt
die Wall Street in Panik
die ganze Welt spielte verrückt
was wir an den Börsen in New York London
und Warschau beobachteten
wir nicht verstehen
wir wurden nervös
die erste Reaktion der Regierung war die
Beschränkung der Ausgaben
die Finanzkrise hat uns nicht gut getan
wir sind schließlich Exporteure
insbesondere nach Osten zum Beispiel
nach Russland und in die Ukraine
ein größeres Haushaltsdefizit höhere
Staatsschulden aber fürs erste Lith die
Realwirtschaft in Polen nicht ebenso
wenig der
banksektorung in der Verfassung an das
Bruttoinlandsprodukt geknüpft
das trug maßgeblich zu geringen
Verschuldung bei die uns gemeinsam mit
verantwortungsvoller Steuerpolitik in
eine solide finanzielle Lage brachte
wir waren nicht durch die guten Jahre
vor der Krise unvorsichtig geworden
als seine Nachbarn doch wir waren
besorgt dass die Krise von unseren
Nachbarstaaten überschwappen würde
eine solche Krise ist wirklich
ansteckend eine Krise der Angst die
Angst überwältigt zuerst die schwächsten
und befällt dann die Stärkeren
und das geht nur durch internationalen
Zusammenhalt
[Musik]
Polen war in einer stärkeren Position
als die anderen Länder
warum Griff der IWF Polen mit
Unterstützung über die flexible
Kreditlinie unter die Arme
Polen war der ideale Kandidat
ein politisch starkes Land auf das die
Krise der Nachbarstaaten dennoch
überzugreifen
drohteregend dass manchmal
Entscheidungen ohne Kenntnis der
Situation in einem bestimmten Land
getroffen werden
perfect time es war der perfekte
Zeitpunkt für den IWF sein neues
Instrument zu nutzen
Poland wars als starke Wirtschaft mit
einem soliden Fundament was zusätzlich
half und der Regierung eine bessere
Verhandlungsbasis bei Investoren und auf
dem Markt gab
an den Fakten hat sich nichts geändert
aber die Wahrnehmung dieser Fakten ist
anders die flexible Kreditlinie war ein
klares Zeichen dass der IWF an Polen
glaubte und somit auch an die ganze
Region
diese Krise war eine einmalige Chance
wir dachten es würde vielleicht 30 40
Jahre dauern bis wir zu unseren Brüdern
in der EU aufschließen können würden
dank ihrer Rezession und unserem
stabilen Wachstum werden wir dieses Ziel
schneller erreichen können
wir gelernt dass politische
Entscheidungsträger erstaunliches
leisten können wenn sie in einer
schwierigen Lage den Mut haben zu
handeln
[Musik]